in this video I want to do some examples
looking at distributions in particular
different features and distributions
like clusters gaps and Peaks so over
here I want to do with some examples
which of the following are accurate
descriptions of the distribution below
select all that apply so the first
statement is the distribution has an
outlier so an outlier is a data point
that's way off of where the other data
points are it's way larger or way
smaller than where all of the other data
points seem to be clustered and if we
look over here we have a lot of data
points between 0 and 6 and let's just
think about what they're measuring this
is shelf time for each apple at Gore
gorgeous gorgeous grocer so for example
we see there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 apples that
have a shelf life of 0 days so they're
they're about to go bad you see you have
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 apples that are going to
be good for another day you have two
apples that are going to be good for
another 6 days and you have one Apple
that's going to be good for 10 days and
this is unusual this is an outlier here
it has a way larger cell shelf life than
all of the other data so I would say
this definitely does have an outlier we
just have this one data point sitting
all the way to the right way larger way
more shelf life than everything else so
it definitely has an outlier and this
one would be the outlier the
distribution has a cluster from 4 to 6
days and we indeed do see a cluster from
4 to 6 days a cluster you can imagine
it's a bit it's a grouping of data
that's sitting there or you have a
grouping of apples that have a shelf
life between 4 and 6 days and you
definitely do see that cluster there and
since I already selected two things I'm
definitely not going to select none of
the above so let me check my answer let
me do let me do a few more of these
which of the following are accurate
descriptions of the distribution below
and once again we're going to select all
that apply
so the distribution has an outlier so
let's see this distribution I do have a
data point here that's at the high end
and I have another data point here
that's at the low end I don't have any
data points that are sitting far far
above or far below
the bulk of the data if I had a data
point that was out here then yeah I
would say that was a outlier to the
right or a positive outlier if I had a
data point way to the left off the
screen over here maybe that would be an
outlier but I don't really see any
obvious outliers all the data it's
pretty clustered it's pretty clustered
together so I would not say that the
distribution has an outlier the
distribution has a peak at 22 degrees
yeah it does indeed look like we have
and let's just look at we're actually
measuring high temperature each day in
Edge tin Iowa in July so it does indeed
look like we have the most number of
days that had a high temperature at 22
most number of days in July had a high
temperature at 22 degrees Celsius so
that is a peak and you can see it if you
imagine this is kind of a mountain this
is a peak right here this is a high
point you have the at least locally you
have the most number of days at 22
degrees Celsius so I would say it
definitely has a peak there since I
selected something I'm not going to
select none of the above let's do a
couple more of these which of the
following are accurate descriptions of
the distribution below so the first one
the distribution has an outlier so let's
see this number of guests by day at sets
sandwich shop so let's see the lowest
the loads they have so they have no days
no days where he had between 0 and 19
guests no days we had between 20 and 39
guests
looks like there's about nine days where
he had between 40 and 59 guess looks
like 20 days where he had between sixty
and seventy nine guests all the way that
looks like this is maybe eight days that
he had between 180 and 199 guests but
the question of outliers there doesn't
seem to be any day where he had an
unusual number of guests there's not a
day that's you know way out here where
he had like 500 guests so I would say
this this distribution does not have an
outlier the distribution has a cluster
from 0 to 39 guests so 0 to 39 guests is
right over here is 0 to 39 guests and
there's no days where he had between 0 &
39 guests either 0 to 19 or 20 to 39
so there's definitely not a cluster
there I would say that the cluster would
be between we're days at
between 40 and 199 guests definitely not
0 & 39 there's no days that were between
0 & 39 guests so I would say none of the
above very confidently let's do one more
of these which of the following are
accurate descriptions of the
distribution below
the distribution has a peak from 12 to
13 points let me see what this what this
is what this is measuring or what this
what this data is about test scores by
student and miss frines class so you had
one student who got between a 0 and a 1
on on the 20-point scale so got between
I guess you may be out of 20 questions
got it between 0 & 1 points and then you
see that there's no students got between
2 & 3 or 4 & 5 or 6 and 7 then we have
another student who got between 8 & 9
looks like 3 students got between 10 and
11 and then we keep increasing this
looks like it's about 12 students got
but either a 16 or 17 or something in
between maybe if you could get decimal
points on that on that test and then
looks like 10 students got from 18 to 19
all right so this says the distribution
has a peak from 12 to 13 points 12 to 13
points there were five students but this
isn't a peak if you just go to 14 to 15
probably you have more students so this
is definitely not a peak if you were
looking at this as a mountain of some
kind you definitely wouldn't describe
this point as a peak you would say this
distribution has a peak has the most
number of students who got between 16
and 17 points so that's the peak right
there not 12 to 13 points I wouldn't I
would not select that first choice the
distribution has an outlier well yeah
look at this you have this outlier most
of the students scored between 8 and 19
points and then you have this one
student who got between 0 & 1 it's
really an outlier you even see this you
know when you look at it visually it's
not even connected to the rest of the
distribution it's way to the left if
something is way to the left or way to
the right that's an outlier if it's like
kind unusually low or unusually high so
I would say this distribution definitely
does have an outlier and I'm not going
to pick none of the above since I found
a choice and I think we're all done